thank you pete
um so as pete mentioned so just a quick
overview that i'm not that i too i'm
from the first bubble actually before
the first bubble so yes i'm old
um but beginning my career i spent kind
of in the classic like c
plus plus desktop application business
and then i moved into
kind of a managerial role reluctantly as
as many people do
in our business and then i started
working um
at amplify at the time it's called
wireless generation that's where i met
headgear who's in the front row where i
was where i became a
director of engineering which kind of
was like a grandiose title for not a
very grandiose position
um and then i decided to what to move
over to spotify because i was really
interested in the culture really
interested in what they were doing from
a product perspective as well as an
engineering perspective
and as usual like not everything was as
rosy as
you know all the blog posts and
presentations uh were
or put out there but it was really
interesting and so far it's been a
really great learning experience
um during that process as i've gotten
more
in tune with management and figuring out
how to manage people grow organizations
grow
grow teams i've become really interested
in the effect of culture
the effect of or the structure of an
organization and the impact that has
you know i think back in the beginning
of my career i was
naive and thought hey you just gather up
the best engineers you can find and it
all work magic will happen
which you know i think at a small scale
probably does work that's how good ideas
are formed it's how things start out but
as you start to grow it becomes a little
bit more challenging it's just not about
finding the best engineers it's not
about finding the smartest people in the
room it's about finding the right people
that can work together it's about
finding the right culture that fits
yours and there's not one to fit them
all you can look at google you can look
at facebook
great organizations to support their
engineers but does it fit your needs
does it fit what you want to build
um and i think those are the things that
i've been thinking about a lot
over the last couple of years so
one of the things that kind of does the
beginnings of this talk in the
beginnings of me thinking about career
development
was looking at my father my father and
me i spent many years thinking we were
complete opposites we were completely
different
he was blue collar working in skilled
labor within the
automotive industry i'm working i went
to college and graduated and got a
white-collar job
building software so we spent many years
just not being able to communicate about
that and talking about that
unfortunately he passed away and i never
had that conversation with them but
during that process
i started thinking about is it really
that different i'm building software
which is a skilled position that
required certain trainings
he built machines that built cars that
required a certain training
certain skill set is it really that
different um
you know he quickly became a journeyman
uh which in the trade meant that you
were able
to be able to work alone and you would
be able to build machines but you
weren't a master you weren't the ones
like developing new process these new
things
uh you know one of the things that that
struck me with him too is he never once
felt pressure to move into management
and i could probably guess that most
people in this room have worked in large
organizations that felt that pressure
oh you need to move up you need to climb
you need to go you need to
start managing people and you need to
stop engineering and go this route
and maybe we'll all be ctos which is
true for some of us but it's not true
for all of us
and myself included
so a couple of things that are hard to
read so one of the things
is um i want to cover a little bit about
how
spotify is organized because i think
that influences a lot of what our
culture is
i think in a well-tuned organization
culture can kind of manifest itself both
in structure as well as the people that
are attracted to that structure
so this this slide is just a kind of the
promotional piece of
you know we're big and we're getting
bigger um but the more interesting thing
is you know
everybody is now an agile company and
and moving forward with
hey how do we become even more lean how
do we come even faster
and all of those are buzz words
sometimes it works sometimes it doesn't
in spotify's case it started as a place
where we were using agile we read the
textbook
we started processing that we hired in
project managers called them agile
coaches and said hey let's do agile it's
great
and it worked quite well at the small
scale but then we started hitting uh
problems we
we're finding that the agile process was
getting in the way
so the initial reaction was let's be
really agile and not do any process
which of course worked out really well
um
and what what did work out well though
is as we grew we started
letting the teams that sell for self
forming teams actually start defining
what their processes were some followed
scrum and sprints and
in that sort some decided that kanban
was a better approach some decided that
hey we don't need anything we're just
going to meet once a day to talk about
make sure we're on the right page and
move forward
and the idea being let's not constrain
that because sometimes good ideas come
out of those experiments and sometimes
failures can teach you something so let
people explore those things
um but we're continuously tweaking the
process but one of the things that we've
been thinking a lot about lately is as
we started to grow and
how many people have read the white
paper about spotify structure
or seen the video about a third
quarter but one of the things that we
started doing was when we first started
growing we said
every team is a startup they're not
going to block on another team they're
not going to block on anybody else
they're just going to charge forward as
if they were a startup which worked
great
in that 50 to 100 person range because
at that scale you can't really be just
this lean mean
machine that you know a 20 startup can
be but
if you break that up you can actually do
that but the problem that we started
having was alignment
and for those of you that use the
product you know about a year ago
it looked like a different product every
time you went to a different view it
looked a little different it felt a
little different the
things even the fonts were a little
different at times some were dark some
were light
and it really looked like a product that
was developed by multiple teams because
guess what it was
developed by multiple teams so we
started thinking a lot about the
alignment issue
and so on one hand we have you know
extreme alignment which if anybody's
ever worked for companies um
that start with m and then like
microsoft um
you know they have high alignment like
their products are in apple
apple is another great example of places
that have high alignment because they
have great structures to provide
that alignment but what they don't
necessarily provide is a lot of autonomy
on the other hand if you have extreme
autonomy which is where spotify was you
have
do whatever you want and hopefully it'll
work out and
most people think of this as a choice
which which model do we want to be
and what we decided was it was really
just a false choice it doesn't matter
it's not a binary choice and instead we
started looking at a grid pattern
about low alignment low autonomy is like
the danger zone you don't ever want to
be there
because you're not getting any benefits
and you're having a huge cost
so this is you know micromanaging
organization we've probably all worked
in those organizations or
have nightmares about them
and then we move up to high alignment
and in the high alignment you know we
have
low autonomy high alignment say we need
to cross the river
now build us a bridge so it's it's a
management structure that's really about
solving the solutions for you and you
become an implementer
that's great for certain people wasn't
what i wanted
and everyone's in alignment what we're
striving for at spotify is kind of this
this the holy grail which is high
autonomy and high alignment i don't know
how close we're going to get to that
it's a work in progress but here we say
we need to cross the river
presents the problem figure out how
how do we do that that's where the
autonomy comes in so the team
collaborates
innovates figures out how to solve that
problem move forward
so this is kind of like where we want to
be
where spotify actually is is somewhere
between
here and up there so we're in this area
of entrepreneurial organization
where chaos is okay because you're
trying to build something you're trying
to get it out there you're trying to vet
your ideas
um but you don't know if it's gonna work
so why are you gonna spend a lot of time
about alignment
instead let's push forward get it out
there we're moving from
high up high autonomy low alignment and
trying to get the more alignment without
losing that autonomy
so in this model you have your manager
that's just hoping that things are going
to work out and this is your founder
your start early startup founders
for those people in the room
so what we decided as we started scaling
past that kind of hundred mark we
started thinking about what
how do we organize the company and what
we wanted to do was organize the company
that wasn't going to completely break
our culture our startup culture
but we did need that alignment and the
way we started looking at it was we
started having tribes and the
the nomenclature is is not important
what the
names are but we wanted to distinguish
it from kind of the more
traditional models so that there wasn't
confusion there wasn't any implications
so we used tribe
the whole tribe model to to to name that
so we basically said tribes which are
departments or areas of
areas of interest each squad has a po
and a cross-functional team the great
thing about that is that gives you your
autonomy
but how do we get our mastery how do we
get our
cohesion amongst the team and that's
when we develop this idea of a chapter
so the chapter is basically an area of
expertise
and has a chapter lead which is what i
am
and we manage people for me it's the
back end engineers but there's also
front end mobile
qa agile coaches everything you can
think of we have
chapters for that to manage that group
of people so here we're doing our work
stream
here we're doing our how do we become
better engineers or how do we become
better at our craft
then we have this idea of guild since
we're a large company now of 600 people
or 600 engineers
some in stockholm some in san francisco
and another site in
sweden and in new york how do we kind of
stay connected with
our counterparts in the other offices it
came up with this guild idea which is
basically it's a meetup but it's
internal within spotify and it's people
that talk
it's people that go to open spaces it's
people that have
meetups and different things within the
organization of course that was the
model
the reality is a little bit more messy
so chapters
are supposed to be contained within a
tribe because you get the whole
autonomy but autonomy with a mission but
as we grow we don't want you know one
manager managing one
one person so we end up having
cross-tribe managers
and the guilds get a little messy
because sometimes they don't line up
well with our
chapters and one thing that we realized
is we have to be actually comfortable
with that
you have to be uncomfortable with a
little bit of chaos we're trying to add
some sort of uh uh control over the
organization
but we don't want to have too much or
we're a different organization we've
changed our culture too much
so one of the things with aligned
autonomy is you have to have a clear
mission you have to have
clear leaders who are setting what that
mission is and then the teams are going
to kind of
come around and actually look at that
and actually charge forward with what
that mission is
you know we we liken it to a band
because you know
four people playing instruments is
pretty terrible unless they're actually
aligned
and then they're playing a song and
they're actually doing well plus
it's our music theme
um one of the other things that we want
from our culture and that makes this
model work because it's very
um we don't have any heart we don't have
as much hierarchy we don't have as much
command and control
we don't want people with egos we don't
want people to think they're the best
thing
ever instead in in fact we passed on
people that you know
other organizations would be happy to
have because they would come in and
disrupt that culture
and i think that's one of the things
that you know as you guys build um your
organizations and as
as i move on to other things in the
future and build organize build
different organizations
you have to be aware of is you don't
want to disrupt your culture too much
because that's part of what made you
uh made you what you are
so what one of the things that struck me
when i joined
uh spotify outside of um all of the
other um
kind of chaotic elements was there
wasn't a lot of thought put behind how
do we develop careers we decided that we
wanted this culture of
minimal structure just enough to get by
but what what's the path of a developer
who doesn't want to become a manager
there wasn't a lot there it turns out
there was some but it was hard to find
so i started thinking about that like i
said with my father is you know he had a
different career path than me
but even though we have some similar
similarities so one of the things i
started looking at was
okay so we have this linear ladder
linear ladder is very easy because you
join you become an intern you become a
junior developer you become a senior
developer
architect team lead whatever the titles
might be and eventually make it to the
vp of engineering and the cto and
everything's great
how many people in this room are going
to be ctos probably a larger number than
normal because
we're in a startup community right but
not everyone is cut out for that not
everyone wants that it takes a certain
skill set a certain interest
so why are we forcing everybody up this
instead of giving people choices
um so one of some of the good things
about this is it's familiar right it's
most companies in america actually
operate in some fashion like this at
least in
a white collar and a lot of the blue
collar as well
you know each rung is clearly defined so
it's really as a manager it's attractive
because i can say oh
you want to climb to the next rung
here's exactly what you need to do
and i can help coach you and get you
there so it's really attractive because
it makes my job easier
you know it's very clear on what is
expected of people it's very clear
where you're going so if that doesn't
match maybe you need to look elsewhere
so it's very good it's very clear to
have that conversation
it's also easy to get resources it's
very easy for me to go to the cto of
spotify and say
so-and-so is doing really well they want
to take the next step into leadership
here's what they need to do they need
this training course they need this time
they need this
we need to start rolling people on to on
to their their structure
and we need to get them some experience
that's an easy conversation to have
it's also very easy for the cto to kind
of look at people who he may not know
personally
and say i know exactly what value
they're adding to the corporation
because
they are a senior or principal or staff
or whatever moniker we put on them
it's also very explicit so it's very
easy to be recognized i mean
we can work in organizations where
somebody gets promoted and you make a
big deal about it we send out a notice
we have a party and we make a big deal
about it so recognition is very easy
and if you're sensing a theme there is a
theme which is it's easy
but what's the danger it's very simple
but there is a cost which is it's
often not that simple we may
have great ideals and set out to say
this is exactly what it means to become
a senior engineer
but when we come down to it it's really
qualitative there's very few
quantitative things that we can take
into account
you're going to take into account lines
of code architecture meetings that they
had
bugs that they created or bugs that they
fix it's all bogus
so at the end of the day we're trying to
create a system that's very
discreet but it's at the end of the day
it's all about people
and it's all about um ambiguity
we've also preferred to keep our
structure flat so we wanted to kind of
define our positions based around
the fact that you have a role and that
role different people will fill that
role differently
and that's great and that's okay and
should be rewarded but the fact is that
your titles and your in your structure
should be defined by that role
so for example from an engineer to the
cto it's
engineer chapter lead who is the the
manager role
then we have a tri bleed and then at cto
it's pretty it's not flat but it's
pretty
pretty flat for uh six to seven hundred
engineers
the other problem is kind of part of the
positive part of the positive it's
really simple and you can see where
you're going but what happens when you
don't fit that mold
so part of the negative is it doesn't
fit everyone's needs it doesn't really
allow for people to grow in a way that
makes sense to them
and it also i think this is what really
got me was it starts promoting people
out of what they're actually good at and
what they're actually interested in
um i i'm working with a colleague now
who keeps telling me he wants to be a
chapter leader when i ask him do you
want to manage people no no no no i just
i want more role i want a bigger role
and more responsibility well
okay but chapter lead means that you
manage people okay well i'll do that if
it means more
influence within the company and i just
think that's looking at it the wrong way
um there's also no way to try new things
out so moving uh
moving up means that you've got a
promotion what happens if that doesn't
work out
what happens if you realize you're not
good at that or you're not enjoying that
how many of us in this room would get a
promotion and six months later say
you know what i'm going to take a step
down take a step down and pay
take a step down and try to tell my
colleagues this is not a big issue it's
just
i tried something that didn't work out
that's a really difficult move to make
emotionally and psychologically
so all that ends up creating a factory
of ejecting people because there can be
only so many managers
we're not going to ever have an
organization which has a one-to-one
relationship between managers and
employees
so what happens when you're ready to
make that next step and there's not a
place for you
well you're going to leave the company
well that's not great for the company
that's not great for the engineer to
potentially if they really enjoyed their
job
and then they might promote people
beyond their ability so this is the
stereotypical that extends well past
tech
and at the end of the day the
engineering says that you know every
choice has
has its consequences and you have to
pick what you want to optimize for and i
think this
optimizes for simplicity it also assumes
that plateauing is bad
i would argue that plateauing is not bad
that if you want to be an individual
contributor and you're really awesome at
it
and you just want to get better at that
great go for it
who said who am i to say that you should
be a manager just because
it's higher up on a graph somewhere
so i started thinking there has to be a
better way so one of the ways that's
kind of gaining popularity is this idea
of multiple ladders so
now we have okay you want to be an
individual contributor that's great
let's create a ladder for
that and at some point in your career
you have to make a choice do you want to
be manager do you want to be
an architect or principal engineer
architect in this model
so this is great because now i have a
way to not manage people but still grow
um so it
kind of reduces that or mitigates that
problem of
people getting promoted into management
positions that really don't like working
and managing people it's a certain skill
that not everybody wants or has
or interests has it also still clearly
sets up easy ways to recognize people so
you're still getting those benefits of
the latter
still it sets up clear routes and roles
so it still sets up that career path
and it's still familiar because ah it's
just another ladder but it's different
roles and
there's a different structure to it but
it's not all that complex
but of course i think this is also
limited um because it still has some of
those negative impacts of a ladder it's
still very explicit what it takes to
move up the ladder
can't accommodate everybody it usually
gets muddled
i know you can't tell because it's a
bitly link but this is the a
a discussion piece around google's
structure
and i'm not going to disc google they
are they are great and what they have
works for them but they also have
thousands of more engineers than i have
and at certain scales you have to give
up certain things and one of those
things that you might have to give up is
being able to accommodate everybody
you can't you know the 80 20 rule at
google is very
very hard because 20 is a huge number of
people
um and um or i'm sorry 80 and so you
have to come up with constructs that
work at scale
i would argue that most people aren't at
that scale and
those complexities that they've created
are really difficult
notwithstanding that they start at 3 and
end at 11 for some reason
and it still assumes that the only way
to grow is through more responsibility
and influence what about
just getting better what about just
being a better programmer
you know how many people have been
programming for 15 years
and are much better programmer than they
were when they first started out
i mean that was me before before moving
into somewhat management career
you know and and we should be able to
reward them we should be able to have
pass for that does that mean they're
going to be getting the
extreme raises of that rock star who's
putting in late nights and doing
everything imaginable
no but that's not what everybody needs
they still want to be recognized for
what they're doing they still want to be
recognized
or to be compensated for that
and that it's not as clear-cut as just
climbing a ladder
it also doesn't really address that
issue of how do you experiment
you know transitioning between
management and
individual contributors still very
difficult you know how many people are
going to say
i worked with one one engineer my my
life who i'm currently working with
who actually stepped down from an
engineering position or a management
position
to become an engineer again it was
difficult even though it's what he
really wanted
and it took a lot of work um
that said i think it can be part of the
solution i think it is an improvement
over the single ladder
um and at some scale it might be
necessary we're actually
exploring this now i'm on a working
committee that do we want a career
ladder what does that career ladder look
like from a from an individual
contribution
i don't know if i buy into it um but
that's the part of the discussion that's
part of the
part of our culture as we discuss things
and we figure out as a group what's the
best thing
so that brings us to what what are the
right things so
at the end of the day i started figuring
out what is career development it's not
about
climbing some ladder but what are people
actually looking for when they want to
get promoted everybody wants promoted
everybody wants that but what is it
so i started boiling this down after
large discussions with group of people
just people want to get better at what
they do what what phrase is mastery
people want autonomy i think people have
some some more control over what they do
on a daily day basis whether that's
the projects they work on or how they
execute the projects i also feel that
people want recognition people want to
be
the pat on the back when they do
something really well they want that
feedback mechanism
i also want compensation and i put these
in a specific order for a reason
i think at the end of the day at a
certain point the compensation isn't the
most important thing for everybody
um but it is still there it's still
people want to feel that
hey if i'm doing a great job shouldn't i
be making more than i did last year
the problem with the latter process is
that they usually concentrate on the
recognition
and compensation pieces it's very easy
to say hey if you're a principal
engineer this is what you make and if
you're a senior engineer this is what
you make
it's a very blunt tool like i said it
works for maybe the 80 percent of the
people out there it doesn't work for
for everybody
so what i decide what i decided for my
purposes and for my group is we need to
start thinking about how to optimize for
the career development
my job as a manager is not to make my
job as a manager easier
my job as a manager is to make career
development easier
it's to make my engineers more
productive it's to make the bottom line
uh more attractive it's to push forward
the company mission it's not to make my
job easier
but i think we continually look at ways
to make manager because that's human
nature
i want to make my life a little easier
so i can go home and play with my kid
i don't want to make more work for
myself but one of the things that we
started exploring
at spotify is how do we start looking at
what we've referred to as non-linear
things so instead of only having that
upward mobility path
how can we have things that are more
horizontal how can we allow people to
grow
recognize people and get to this idea of
mastery
and recognition without forcing
everybody up this ladder
so two of the ways that we started
looking at it and this is not the end
end of the discussion
but two of the ways we started looking
at that are called loops and add-ons and
i'm
going to go through what we do for these
so loops are
basically tools to help uh direct career
development
initially i thought of loops as the
annual review process that everybody has
at larger corporations right as you
gather up feedback from your peers or
the peers of the people that you're
working with
you figure out how well i've done this
year and guess what that goes into some
mathematical equation and comes out with
a number that says that's erased for the
year
the way we've actually started working
with it at spotify is
that loops are a tool for the manager in
the
employee to actually work out a career
path has nothing to do with it has very
little to do with salary
so they actually don't happen at salary
review time they happen when the
employee wants them to happen
and they they and you will solicit
feedback you will
start a conversation with your
management and your
your colleagues and have a conversation
about what am i doing that's great what
am i doing that needs work where am i
going and what am i doing
and that you can have these as
frequently or as infrequently as you
want
so this is the first tool so again it's
employee driven this is this is the key
part of it it's not the
hey it's been a year let's let's finally
have a conversation that we should have
probably been having
earlier let's have that conversation now
because i have to put a number into a
spreadsheet that tells you what you
raise is going to be this year
we still have that process it's not all
all great
but this process is about that feedback
the other interesting part of it that i
haven't experienced before is that it's
not anonymous
so most most companies when you're doing
a review the manager will solicit
feedback it'll kind of boil that down
into common themes and then present that
to the user so that you're not
setting up a reaction between two
employees that says hey
you bitched about me what's up what i
found though is that when you start
having
when you remove that anonymity you
actually start getting a little bit more
honest
and you actually get a little bit more
constructive it becomes less of a you
know joe really pissed me off because he
did this and becomes a
hey joe i think you could work on this
and actually gives meaningful
suggestions to people from a colleague
and this is actually borne out if you if
you look through and i can't release it
because it's all confidential for the
people
but if you look through it it's actually
really interesting to see how helpful it
is
and it's much more helpful than if i as
a manager would actually describe it to
them and say
well some people in the team are think
that you're a little bit too aggressive
when you're making your architectural
arguments
but actually hearing it from people is
meaningful
as a manager i'm also giving feedback
which is also not anonymous and so that
they know what feedback i'm giving so
they can kind of start figuring out what
what the impression is from the
different different sides of
uh the equation and that drives the
discussion so it becomes much more of a
discussion as
as opposed to a feedback session as
opposed to of hey here's the things i
think you need to work on as a as an
engineer and becomes much more of a
this is where i want to go and this is
my strengths and my weaknesses how do we
actually get support for that and how do
i grow and what's your advice
they're not directly tied to salary
reviews so
i think our human resources department
would say they're not at all
related to the salary review process
because they happen at different times
but you know we're human so if i'm doing
a loop and somebody's really struggling
is that going to impact the salary
review process probably
if we do a loop and someone's really not
getting it out of the park is that going
to affect
our salary process probably but it's not
a direct it's not a fill out a form and
then some mathematical equation
at the end of the day it's a qualitative
discussion about salary
it's also qualitative about career
development but they're two separate one
is forward looking or backward looking
which is your salary review
one is using that that review to kind of
project forward
and i'm not going to give you a salary
adjustment based on what i think you
might do next year i'm going to give you
a salary adjustment on what you've
actually done
so that's why they're really two
distinct two pieces
so one of the other things is that we've
been using is this idea of add-ons
so add-ons are
just ways to expand your current role so
these are the people that don't want to
change their role don't want an
advancement in that career path but want
to get better want to expand the
horizons want to get something some more
skills
you know it's probably a little hard to
see up here but the idea is that
the dark lines are your typical ladder
pattern so in our case intern to
engineer engineer chapter lead tribe
lead and
upward but there's also these green dots
which are value added
so maybe you're really interested in
agile methodologies well
you're a developer some organizations
say let the other people deal with that
you focus on development we say
why can't an engineer also help further
agility
why can't they come out and speak so as
you can imagine
i'm working on my speaker add-on why
can't they be a mentor at any different
level
doesn't have to be the manager that's
the mentor in fact you know i really see
my role as not to be the best engineer
on the group because if i was the best
engineer what the hell am i doing
wasting my time managing people and
not engineering but i need to be a
competent engineer maybe i'm really
interested
in architecture and managing people how
do i fulfill that
well i can be a chapter lead who gets
the architecture add-on and i can
participate in the architecture of
spotify
so that's that's the idea of this kind
of non-linear growth pattern
so roles are still defined by the
institutional need so chapter you know
those those basic big circles
the other thing that i think was a lot
more controversial than i thought it was
when i wrote
this slide and i am working on a blog
post about this is that
moving to management is not a promotion
i said this to people within spotify and
i think one person cheered me and about
45 people said what the hell are you
talking about of course it's a promotion
you're getting more pay you're getting
more responsibility you're getting
closer to that cto level
and in reality i don't think it is i
mean at some point
sure there is a promotion model um but
at the end of the day it's a different
role
my role now as a chapter lead is
part-time managing people and part-time
engineer
my job as an individual contributor was
full-time engineer
the cto's job is full-time manager in
managing the structure in the
organization
it's a different role if you ask me you
know even
salary-wise do i deserve a higher salary
because i'm a chapter lead than somebody
who's working on my team
no um i think you know
i think there are chapter leads who
deserve more than a lot of the
individual contributors i also think
there's a lot of individual contributors
that should be compensated and
recognized a lot more than some of the
chapter leads
there's junior chapter leads and they're
learning and they're trying to perfect
their craft
in trying to explore that new role why
why are we tying these two things
together and i don't think
personally i don't think it is a
promotion when i moved into management i
probably actually
if you would have gotten me a few beers
in me i probably would have said it was
a demotion because
it's a whole new world and i felt like i
was a new engineer again
um because i didn't know anything um so
add-ons uh
are doing two things first of all
they're actually growing the engineers
so we
or the individual contributor because it
doesn't just apply to engineers
and allows you to kind of figure out
what you want to grow with and it's
since it's driven by you it's really
driven by your interest and your skill
set
however there's also the business value
side which you know putting my manager
hat on for a minute
is really important as well because we
can't just say hey do whatever you want
all the time because we still have a
mission we
for in our case we're putting it we're
trying to create a new uh you know a new
industry or help create a new industry
um and figure out how to make uh music
available to everybody that's
you know arguably an important mission
and we need to get that done
it's not just about playing um it's
interesting skill set to find
um and again that you choose as an
individual contributor
or as a manager for that matter and it's
supported by the company because there
is this added business value
i'm going to look at ed again here
because we worked with a company that
did this idea of merit badges
and the idea with the mirror badges was
very similar which was hey you can get
the open source mirror badge which means
that you're contributing to open source
projects and you're being a great open
source community member
which was kind of interesting we would
make once a month we'd meet up and say
hey so-and-so got this bad so-and-so got
this badge we joked that we would make
sashes like
girl scouts and boy scouts and that we
would display these things
i think it was really interesting it was
really cool but it wasn't really
supported by the company the support
from the company became
we're going to buy you the merit badges
for three dollars a piece or whatever
they were
which is you know better than a lot of
companies but it wasn't like we're going
to help you get that merit badge
it wasn't that we were going to send you
to training courses become a better
speaker
it wasn't that we were going to let you
go to conferences on the open source
community
just because you were working on that
merit badge the difference with um
spotify is we are doing those things and
we want to the manager works with the
engineer to say oh you want to work on
this add-on first does that make sense
for you
both skill set and interest-wise and
then how are we going to actually get
there and come up with a plan
that may include training sessions
workshops more importantly it might just
be time
you know it might be time off to go to
an event it might be time during your
job to say i'm going to devote 10 of my
time
to learning this new craft and i'm not
developing software during that 10
that's kind of a big commitment from a
company to say stop what you
stop what should we paying you to do and
do this other thing which may or may
not work out you know google famously
had that with their 20 project says take
your 20 and do what you want
the idea being is the uh the one percent
chance that we actually have a good idea
that's marketable
is worth the investment of the 20
similar to similar type of model here
less less structure around it less
definition
so some of the driving forces that kind
of led us down this path
was that we want to do things and tell
people that's that kind of gets to the
recognition piece and the mastery which
is
you can try new things um and tell
people about it
you know sometimes you just get an itch
and say oh i really want to investigate
this new technology
maybe maybe it's not applicable to the
to what we do
but explore it anyways and then tell
people about it
you know you're passionate about maybe
something that's unrelated to your
day-to-day job
really passionate about uh writing maybe
maybe that's a background well why not
explore that why not explore that and
try to marry that to your current role
you'd also like recognition for your
efforts i mean i think we've all worked
in companies where we worked on secret
projects right oh i can't tell my
manager because he might tell me no so
i'm going to spend some time here and
there
um and try to get it done and if it's
successful i'll make a big deal about it
but if it's a failure i won't i won't
i'll downplay it well if you put a lot
of effort into it why isn't it a success
when you tried something and it didn't
work out that's a success you've learned
something
why don't you share that why why aren't
people up clapping for that
um so i think that led us to the add-ons
the other part of it was try something
new is sometimes you don't know what
you're interested in i think i might be
interested
in architecture but i don't know until i
try it um
you know you're getting a little bored
maybe you just want to shake it up a
little bit
that's not there's nothing wrong with
that you also
might want to try to do something new
without transitioning a few years ago i
decided that i wanted to kind of explore
what it would be to be a product owner
i thought it was really exciting to be
able to like help drive the product it
was a technology
team um so i stepped up into my manager
said i want to be
i want to be that product owner we need
one i'll fill that role
about three months in i realized what a
monumental mistake i made
because i hated it but it was really
hard to back out of because i went in
full force
and i was spending 75 of my time in that
as opposed to saying
hey maybe i should work with a product
owner and actually see what that's about
and i can help them
in their job but i don't have to jump in
with both feet
that opportunity wasn't available and
then you're not sure you want to switch
roles
again you know you go into this
management role it might sound exciting
but then you get there and realize that
you know like most jobs a lot of it's
monday and a lot of it is
detail-oriented and you might not be
interested so why
all of a sudden get a team of 10 people
and then realize that you don't like it
and have no way of stepping out of it
add-on may allow you to lead a project
it might allow you to lead an initiative
so it also gets you out of comfort zone
so just like i said shake it up
maybe you acquire a new skill maybe it's
about learning a new programming
language or maybe it's about learning a
new technique or new technology
push yourself in a new direction
sometimes it's a neat gentle nudging
from the manager too that people are
getting complacent
they're really good at what they do but
sometimes outside experience will help
um and you shake things up and see what
skills that you don't know that you have
that you actually have
um like i said i was reluctantly pushed
into management i think i'm an adequate
manager but i think i'm a much better
manager now than i would have given
myself credit for
10 years ago but i thought i would hate
it i ended up liking it
the only way i got it got to do it was
because somebody pushed me in that
direction
so the other part of it is you can
create you know is that you choose an
add-on or maybe you can define a new one
and the
process of defining a new one is to find
a goal so did what are you trying to do
define metrics so we're big on metrics
that spotify data
rules everything so instead of just
saying i want to be better at open
source what does that actually mean
does it mean that you're contributing to
five open source project does that mean
you own an open source project
to find the help that's needed this is
the key that most most people that have
tried processes like this don't do which
is
what do you actually need from the
company to get what you're done is it
time money what have you
so a few examples and this is a work in
progress so
you know we have speakers road managers
kind of like we don't have project
managers we have agile coaches so road
manager is kind of filling that
that area where we have cross cross
tribe i guess if you if you will uh
initiatives that need to have
have some sort of coordination so we
have road managers help drive that
um coach so this is your agile i want to
be more interested in agile
in evangelist i really like cassandra
and i really want to make cassandra use
that spotify better
well that's an evangelist architect so
looking at the big pic
architecture picture mentor so we're big
on that
the managers are not the mentors some
cases they are but
by default i'm not the mentor of the
people on my team
i'm coaching them and i'm working with
them the mentors come from their
colleagues on the team and sometimes
those colleagues are more junior
and just getting them up to speed on
what spotify's like sometimes those
mentors are much more senior and trying
to bring the junior developers a little
bit
elevate their skill set writer so uh we
have
haka for those uh out there that are
interested in writing they're writing a
workshop
we're on our second session of workshop
where we're working with i believe 10
engineers myself included on how do we
become better writers so that we can
start talking about things in the
external community
trainer so we don't have any trainers
within spotify outside of our business
side so
how do we train people on how to do
development how to do
uh things within spotify open sourcer
that i mentioned before
so a couple of closing remarks um
which is you know it's a work in
progress you know we're testing out
this hypothesis and at the end of the
day it's this hypothesis it's our idea
of what might work
it could be a complete failure in fact
uh we didn't just start this last week
we started this in january 2013 and i
looked it up today was january 2013
when we first rolled this out so for
those doing the math it's uh
you know it's a while it's over a year
and a half and it was a bit slow to
adopt and um but we're refining it
and you know what part of the work in
progress is that well this is a
duplicate slide
so part of what we discovered was that
there are more complexities so
you know being a fairly agile
quick to deliver company one of the
things that we tend to do and this is
probably fairly common
is we tend to have really great ideas
run with them get a prototype out test
whether that prototype works
build a minimum viable product and then
kind of get distracted by the next thing
right it's you know i kind of liken it
to for those of you that seen the movie
up it's the squirrel
um aspect it's where the dog keeps
chasing and keeps chasing after the
squirrel and then gets distracted by the
next squirrel and in in it
you know it's common and i think that
this process suffered a little bit from
that is we had
the 80 of the work done and said hey
let's we got this great idea let's
develop it
and then when it came to actually
rolling it out it kind of fizzled
and nobody was really behind it nobody
was pushing it nobody was talking about
it
another aspect that we struggled with
was defining new ones so i i
on the previous slide i looked i showed
you about i think eight
nine different uh add-ons not all of
those are actually add-ons
those are some of those are my ideas of
what should be add-ons so we rolled out
with six different add-ons
now you can imagine six doesn't cover a
lot of territory of people's interests
and we define no process whatsoever to
define a new one
so that i mentioned the define the goal
define the
the uh the the metrics and then to find
the help that you needed
that's all from my head and a couple
other engineers who have been recently
thinking about this and refining the
system
so that wasn't there in the initial step
and then the third one which is probably
the much
more important one and harder one to
solve was we concentrated on
what does it take to achieve an add-on
and spent very little time on what does
it mean once you've achieved it
so push back from people in management
and higher levels of management were
like oh that's great so you're just
creating a system where people are going
to game the system and get a bunch of
achievements and get all their merit
badges
and you know like all the games on our
phones and let's collect all the metals
but what is that actually adding in
because nobody's actually using those
skills that they we've paid for and that
we've invested in
to actually further their teams or
further their products
which is which is totally a valid
concern and a valid feedback
so one of the things that looking
forward is how do we reward not the
achievement of the add-on but the actual
application of the add-on
so we want to support add-ons so that
you can fail
or you can try something that didn't
work out and that's okay so we're not
going to give you demerits for that
but we're also not going to consider it
success in in
we don't want to tie salary to add-ons
because then you're just going to say
well for five thousand dollars i can
learn how to be an agile
coach and for another 3 000 i can start
working on architecture and pretty soon
i'm making 500 000
a year we don't want that model but
offering nothing to the company
so instead what we want to say is you
have all the freedom in the world to
explore these options and explore these
things and we're going to support that
but we really want you to start applying
some of those as well
and it gives me a tool as a manager
working with people to really call
people out and say
hey look you're going to 14 different
things and trying to do way too much
let's focus on one or two things and see
if that works out and then let's figure
out how to actually apply that
so those are some of the things that
that caused us i think to not be a
failure but to be a little bit more of a
slow start
a bunch of us are now trying to
help correct those problems but at the
end of the day we could just be wrong it
could just be a bad model
um so we'll see
so one of the reasons that i started
giving this talk and i've given it a
couple times now
is that you know i think this is a big
area within tech that we haven't spent
very or we've spent very little time on
because it's very easy to slap a ladder
on it and call it done
i don't think that's the end of it i
think as a
as a manager and more importantly as a
person actually in the system i want
something better
i don't want to be forced down a path
that is simple i want to be forced on a
path that makes sense for me
and i think the only way we're going to
actually solve it is as group it's not
going to be what spotify does or what
google does or what
facebook does it's going to be what
everybody
starts having a conversation around it
it's going to be people who are
interested talking about it
and i think that was at the end of it
not so much
my goal is to solve the problem but to
start talking about it so that we can
start
figuring it out so that's my email
address um
the obligatory we're hiring um slide
and what's funny is i've had this slide
on the different presentations i've done
for
probably the entire year i've been at
spotify and it just occurred me to the
other day that that's
actually a spotify employee um it's not
just stock footage
so while i was interviewing for spotify
i i there was a lull in my
my uh my uh recruiting because everybody
in the company flew to stockholm
for a pro party big party called summer
jam which is what you see a picture of
so it's at a hangar in stockholm sweden
what you can't quite see is there's a
band playing here
and all of these are spotify employees
and significant others that are just
probably half drunk and just having a
good time which is
just kind of fun that i just thought it
was stock footage
so i kind of breezed through a lot of
the stuff
i'm betting people have questions um
so we have plenty of time for questions
if anybody has
this i guess
so could you talk about what the process
is like
for okay the engineer comes up with the
this is what i want to do
as an add-on that's what i want to do in
my own time
how does that get up the chain or
whatever
so the question was for for the people
who are going to be listening to this
later
the question was you know how do we how
do we bubble this up and how do we
actually define a new thing and actually
get accepted
so the the whole idea of autonomy
actually is pervasive within
spotify so the cto is
is not there to be an approver instead
he's there as a
i'm going to pull the emergency brake of
something i think is going off the rails
so the idea is that um we work on that
as
as individuals or as a small group
figure out what we actually want to do
we communicate that up through you know
whether it's through wikis google docs
different emails you know different
mechanisms
um in this case it's usually a wiki
although we're slowly moving a lot of
that stuff to google docs
um and then we define it there open it
up for people it's not closed it's not
secret
and then if anybody has an objection or
has some input they're
um they're encouraged to present that
whether that's cto or just another
engineer
but it's really an organization where
it's about
do don't ask um which helps
if it was a little bit more a structured
hierarchy then
or a little bit more micromanaging then
it would be a lot harder because then
you have even in
a fairly flat organization we would
still have to talk to the chapter lead
then the tribe lead and then the cto
instead we just kind of do that and you
know it's much easier to ask for
forgiveness and permission um and nobody
really calls us
out on whether or not you should have
done that
okay so how do you know that
what you're doing is actually better or
worse
than the more traditional approaches
located so the question is how do we
know what's better if it's better
it's a really hard question just like
anything else when it comes to crew
development because there's
the metrics are pretty scarce one metric
is we do a lot of employee happiness
um so every quarter we do we do a study
and we we talk to people and we you know
sometimes it's part survey part
communication part talking
and some of those metrics on that is how
are you how are you feeling about your
career development so to be honest the
fact that the add-ons hasn't haven't
been working and haven't been taken off
showed up in these reports and what we
saw was that our scores in that area of
career development were actually
lower than they had been in a long time
and that's what started us leading
along the lines of do we need this
career ladder in addition to the add-ons
do we need this
individual contributor ladder of senior
developer principal developer what have
you
and that's formed a working group so
that feedback loop is going to be
helpful because i think we're going to
probably have that
second ladder in conjunction with the
add-ons
retention rate um our retention rate is
not grow i'd say it's not great across
our industry
to be honest i think average and within
tech is staying two years or less with a
company
um some places less than a year some
places maybe as high as three but most
places
um don't have great retention so i think
that's something that we're cognizant of
and we started looking at is
what is our average tenure of inter of
people within spotify
how many people are leaving um i think
the industry average is about 10
of your staff a year will will leave um
we're lower than that but not as low as
i would like
um i think we're somewhere in the
neighborhood like eight percent um
and so i think those are the few some of
the few metrics that we can look at is
just the happiness of our employees
i think the other part of it is you know
how much are we still innovating because
i think the business side of this is
that
as we invest more in people the more
innovation will happen the more
um great things will come out of that
you know at the end of the day
um both product wise you know will we
venture
you know how can we add more value to
music from a technology standpoint we
you know when
i started we were at about 20 million
users and you just or 25 million users
now we're at over 40 million users so
just in a year that's a pretty
impressive scale so
that takes innovation that takes work if
we're not doing that and we
i think we'll start to falter and i
think
that's a little bit more i would call it
squishy
because it's really hard to tie it
directly to career development
but i think the only way you're going to
be able to innovate like that is keeping
developers happy keeping them engaged
keeping them learning new things
if you have really high turnover and you
have people that are disengaged you're
going to fail at the mission of whatever
that mission is it could be the greatest
product in the world
and you're not going to get it so i
think those are kind of i think
at the end of it it might just be the
sheer success or failure of spotify
it's it's not negative or positive so
the feedback is kind of
oh those exist it's really a knowledge
gap right so when i started
working with engineers i would talk we
would they would hear about add-ons and
they'd be like well how do i do that
and just the sheer amount of effort to
like find information about it so this
goes to the selling
even a great idea i think poorly sold is
a failure
and i think that some of that failure to
sell it
was part of it now if we actually had
everybody that knew about add-ons and
people were unhappy with it i'd be more
than happy to walk away from and say
look
great experiment we learned something
move on but where i came in is
i still think the idea is solid and
nobody half the people or more than half
the people in the organization
don't even know they exist which is not
a good place to be so part of what i
wanted it was to correct some of the
things that
we saw as problematic and then we're
going to go and
this road manager idea of like and let's
actually talk about this with real
people
let's sit down with teams let's stand
with managers and and chat about it
to get that feedback going um because we
could be completely off
in left field
oh yeah so i have a question about this
idea of the matrix where you have
self-directed teams but then you have
chapter leads
how do you guys protect against chapter
leads from having like
uh i guess undue influence on how the
team works by being able to
affect multiple teams across the board
so the question is
um i think boils down to whenever you
look at a matrix model the fear is
oh wow now the people have two bosses
and that is a distinct fear
so part of it is hiring the right
chapter leads to be honest part of it is
is setting the expectations which is
my role as a chapter lead is not to give
people work
if i tell people to do something i
failed instead what i'm
what i should be doing is influencing
how they do their work so we're having
discussions about what does it take to
be a back-end engineer what technologies
are we using what design patterns
those are discussions that are happening
in the chapter so those have an indirect
influence on the work because you could
say
we're going to do things that take twice
as long as this other approach
but those are very indirect um the work
itself comes from the team
um and you know part of my
relationship with my manager is that
he's calling me out because there is a
human reaction to say hey this thing
needs to get done the easiest way to get
it done is to tell
you know so and so to go do it if i do
that i get called out on that both by my
the people on my chapter as well as my
manager
so it's really kind of like calling
people out on their bs
and hiring the right people are the ways
to keep people honest and i think
transparency
helps because if i tell people something
to do something and in their morning
stand up they can't do what their team
needs them to do because i told them
something
that creates a really quick feedback
loop um
is there like 360 reviews that like you
are now accountable to all
the teams not just the people in your
chapter so me as a chapter lead yes
so my reviews come from all my chapter
members as well as the managers that i'm
working with on the different teams as
well as the you know other
uh more senior people on those teams so
that all does influence it it's a very
it's a very it's a cultural thing at the
end of the day which is people are
willing to call people out on their bs
um and that's not frowned upon and
that's not considered politics
that's just considered doing a good
had a question about job about the
add-ons and budgeting
um you mentioned some of the items going
to require you to class or perhaps
you know go to a you know a seminar
these kinds of things
how the how to spotify manage those
those budgets and decide okay
we're going to have so many people fill
this out this much budget
so thankfully so the question is about
how do we budget for this and account
for that
so the way budgeting works is each tribe
has their own budget
part of that budget includes obviously
things like salaries and and
all that stuff but part of it is also
for career development
as it stands what that allows us to do
is it's enough of a pushback
just so that we don't try everything but
so far i haven't had a discussion where
somebody's really wanted to have an
add-on
and there hasn't been a budget because
at the end of the day
and this may be a scale issue at the end
of the day
you know the money's there for for a
certain amount of career development
you know we have rough estimates too you
know you know each and each engineer
should be able to go to a couple
conferences a year
you know if it's really remote maybe one
um so we have these general ideas of
like what's
what's applicable um but at the end of
the day
there's enough pressure to have that
really direct conversation of are you
doing this because you're really
interested are you doing it just apply
yeah and if it's just to play we'll find
some other way for you to have fun
and learn things in a little bit more
budget conscious way
but so far it hasn't been too much of a
constraint that we can't do things
uh curious about like the
the flatness of the org as i mentioned
earlier is
how big chapters can be like are you
you're so you're a chapter leading
back-end engineers but are you
the chapter lead for all back-end
engineers or like how big are the
chapters generally
so um the question is how big are the
chapters and the answer there is because
we were spending so much time working
with people i mean
as you can imagine this process is not
cheap from a labor standpoint
is we try to keep chapters about 10 to
12 in some cases they get a little bit
bigger
so as you can imagine with 600 engineers
there's multiple back end chapters
that's where the guild process comes in
so the guild is basically the idea this
you have these chapters that should be
small enough to be functional teams and
small enough that the manager has time
with each
person but shouldn't be but we still
need that commonality across
the space and so as a guild we'll run
things like on conferences where we'll
gather up once or twice a year
as an entire group the one we just did
in new york was about 100 100 people of
back-end engineers
and we met up at the ace hotel and spent
a day just talking about back-end
engineering
and another day talking about data
processing and data pipelines
with about 80 people so those those
sorts of things are there
but we try to keep it at 10 to 12. so
it's a system that's not optimized for
cost and again it gets back to the
the fact that we have the money to grow
but it's really optimized for
speed of the product and getting things
out there and um
the development of of the engineers and
individual contributors
you seem to describe somewhat of a
static situation in your slides i'm
curious how
uh how things grow so blackberry comes
to life
tomorrow and then suddenly it's 10
million users
how do you spell the blackberry team and
how do you
organize the people around them so the
question is about how do we spin up to
kind of
uh be more dynamic and and be able to
maneuver a large company so um
part of it is having a cross-functional
team so we don't have a blackberry team
or an ios team or
an android team we used to to be honest
we used to have those teams
and we decided to base it around feature
set so for
in your example if blackberry also
became a player and we wanted to be able
to
to support that what we would do is we
would have to recruit people who knew
how to program in blackberry but then we
would add those to the feature teams and
we wouldn't
so it wouldn't be a huge disruption from
the team's mission
it would be the same mission with new
expertise and new personnel and new
new people there are things that do
challenge things we have a platform team
for example that's dedicated to
providing us with
systems and infrastructure and platforms
that we use
as you can imagine that changes out all
the time and so there there's teams
forming and dissolving and reforming
uh the the group that i work on is the
monetization group that's trying to keep
um
the free tier free um by
you know um you know basically ads right
and figuring out better ways to deliver
ads and
user experience so as you can imagine
that changes almost
monthly on what we're actually working
on it's very
challenging and so what we've been
developing is we have a group of
engineers and we keep forming in
and changing teams as as projects come
alive
and the challenge there is to figure out
how to do that with less chaos
you know you want the you want the
agility without the chaos that's
something we do struggle with a little
bit
um and sometimes we get it right and
sometimes we get it wrong
back here
the question is what happens when people
want to make a kind of a bigger shift in
their career and uh try something new
so it's actually happened uh twice with
me once actually today
um so good timing uh so i had one one uh
one gentleman on my chapter who was a
java programmer really not happy with
back in engineering just getting a
little bored and so he wanted to explore
android development
so the initial steps we're sending with
training courses actually learn the
basics of android development and so him
and a group of people went to that
then we set up an exploration where he
was still on my chapter and
i was still working with him and he
started doing more android development
and getting android projects so it was
kind of a slow rollout
and now we're at that stage where he
really enjoys it and we're starting to
roll him over to the mobile chapter so
it wasn't just a
oh you want to do mobile development not
my problem here go go forth and and
go bother him he said it was a much more
organic slow growth thing
and then today i have a front-end web
developer who's really much more of a
full stack developer and has been
concentrating much more on the data
pipeline stuff so we had a conversation
today of how can he start exploring
joining our chapter starting to
participate with our group
without having to go all in and so
that'll be another slow roll out
probably over a couple of months
in the back
you know something that was chosen to be
developed how was it chosen
to build this new thing how's the
decision made
so yeah the question revolves around how
do you have a self-managing team but
still
kind of meet the mission so part of it
is like
resisting the urge to micromanage so it
usually starts with an initiative from
daniel akus who's the ceo of spotify
who may say something as broad as hey we
want a
this is this is part of a true story of
we want to offer a mobile free tier so
up until november of last year if you
were on mobile you had to pay
there was uh and that was just part of
it
um he wanted to be able to have a mobile
free tier and as you can imagine that's
wide reaching there's lots of people
that need to be involved in that so what
happened at that is that rolled down to
the next
set of tier where design had to start
figuring out what would that look like
the legal team had to start working up
on contracts the
labor relations people had to start
reaching out to the labels and say what
does this look like how do you need how
does this structure work for you and
work for us
and then from a technology standpoint we
have to figure out how to build the
thing
because it wasn't some it wasn't going
to just be here's some ads and hear some
songs that we had on the desktop
so really it started with daniel act
making this proclamation and then each
individual
director or um vp saying this is what we
need to do as a group
and that kind of rolls through this team
and if the team feels like they're not
structured or they don't have enough
expertise
that information gets bubbled up and say
look this we can't meet these goals
and that starts a discussion at the
tribe level to say we need more
resources we need to hire we need to
to do things we need to move people
around so it really is one of those
the the uh big picture things are being
pushed down from above
and then there's things coming up from
underneath that kind of meet there
and it really is about discussion it's
not always the easiest discussion
you know product owners don't always
want to have
spend time in tech debt but they get it
if you actually put it together a
compelling case
so the question is is uh how common is
this across spotify and all the
different fields
so and the technology so we really split
the company into kind of technology and
business
on technology it does apply to everybody
which includes product owners
designers uh developers qa
agile coaches so all that add-ons apply
and all these different structures apply
um on the more business side of like
labor relations legal hr those sorts of
things
not so far but that is something that
we're exploring is what
things are they doing that are
applicable to what technology does and
vice versa
that we're trying to see if there's a
commonality
we'll come back
in practice so can you give a sense of
you know how many repos
this results in your first try across
chapters
how far down the sort of micro stack you
embrace them so whether it's
services only for apps or different data
so the question is you know how much
does this organizational structure
influence our architecture quite a bit
so we have tried to structure our
architecture to achieve that autonomy so
it's micro services on the back end
um we have basically the at the bottom
tier a micro service
the tier right above that and then we
have an aggregation service so that the
micro services themselves will never
communicate with one another
so we don't get into these whole like
you know one call results in 47
different things
then we have an aggregation layer so
that the client app we kind of came from
this model where
the application would make multiple like
most ajaxi type of things would like
you'd hit a page and maybe there'd be 47
calls to the site to get all the assets
and we said that's not great so let's
just do one hit so that's where
aggregation services kind of came into
play
so the aggregation services are owned by
a team like the views are owned by a
team but the infrastructure is owned
by all of us the micro services are
usually owned by a team
and then the other part of it is on the
client app side we have
squads that we call container squads and
what their idea is is build the platform
so build the thing that you plug your
future into to make sure things like
build processes are stable to make sure
that the
common things that you need to do are
taken care of make sure
you know they're the ones working with
apple to get things approved and working
with
the android store they're working with
all of those things to provide
our future teams a place to put their
feature and then the future teams really
own their feature
you know and that's a work in progress
with ios it's pretty
it's in one place and with android is in
a different place and they both have
their strength and weaknesses android is
much further along
and they're more continuous deployment
or continuous delivery type of model
whereas um ios is much more structured
around like the development practices
all right thanks chris thank you
that was great